لم نتفق على اتفاقية طويلة الأمد
مع ألمانيا
حتى الآن ، لكننا على استعداد للمناقشة
مع الشركات التي كنا
نناقشها لوضع اتفاقية طويلة الأجل
في مكانها المحتمل وهذه
اتفاقية تجارية بين
الكيانات التجارية التي تميل إليها الولايات المتحدة  بكثافة على
أوروبا في الوقت الحالي لقطع واردات الطاقة الروسية على الفور ،
وهذا ممكن في ذهنك ، وأعتقد
أنك تعرف
استبدال
إمدادات الغاز الروسية ، عليك أن تنظر إلى
الأرقام وعندما تنظر إلى الأرقام
أه اليوم في مكان ما في حدود 30 إلى
40 في المائة من إجمالي المعروض من الغاز
يأتي من روسيا ، حتى نقول في الواقع
إننا نعلم أن أوروبا تستطيع أن
تحل محل هذا الغاز
أه إنه غير ممكن عمليًا ، من
الواضح أن قطر فرصة عظيمة
لأوروبا حيث أن أوروبا تقرضها
واشنطن بشدة  اربح نفسها من الغاز الروسي ،
ما الذي توفره قطر في الوقت الحالي ،
العقود التي نوردها بالفعل إلى
أوروبا هي أغلبية قابلة
للتحويل متنوعة سواء كانت قيد
التنفيذ  ntal europe أو المملكة
المتحدة وما التزمنا به بالفعل
أه للأوروبيين هو أن الأحجام
القابلة للتحويل
لن نحولها لذا سنحتفظ بها خلال هذا
الظرف لإبقائها في أوروبا حتى
لو كانت هناك لعبة مالية لنا
لنصرفنا بعيدًا ، لن نفعل ذلك ،
وهذا تضامنًا مع ما يحدث
في أوروبا من خلال
المشاركة بوضوح في الدعم
وكما وصفته ، فإن التضامن مع أوروبا
في هذا
الوقت من الأزمة
يضر بعلاقاتك مع الكرملين.
أعتقد أنه يفعل ذلك إنه أه أنت
تعلم أننا أه
مورد طاقة كنا نزود
أوروبا طوال الوقت
أه لذا فإن جميع الأحجام التي
نأخذها إلى أوروبا كانت مخصصة
لأوروبا ، لذلك نحن نقول فقط  نحن
نحتفظ بذلك وليس تحويله بعيدًا ،
دعني أضع الأمر بطريقة أخرى ، هل
تختار جانبًا في هذه المرحلة لأنه حتى
الآن لم تختر قطر جانبًا
في هذه الحرب ، فنحن لسنا
على علم من منظور تجاري
لا نختاره  الجانبين نعمل كعمل تجاري
ونقوم بعملنا في مجال الغاز لدينا
مدفوعًا بالأعمال التجارية وليس
بالسياسة ، هل تعتقد أن الغرب يفعل
الشيء الصحيح
في معاقبة جزء الطاقة الروسي
من الصعب التعامل معه ، أعتقد أن
الطاقة يجب أن تبقى بعيدة عن السياسة
لأنها
يعيق التنمية ويمكن أن يؤثر على
الأسعار بالطريقة التي بها ولديه الكثير من
التقلبات